l'intercommunalité gérard maire de son
village de 68 habitants n'a plus les
moyens d'entretenir les 28 km de routes
communales qui sillonne son territoire
son village ne comporte que quelques
maisons ramassées dans un vallon autour
de la mairie et de l'église
mais le territoire de la commune est
très étendue et un tiers de ses
administrés vie dans des fermes ou des
maisons isolées
grâce aux possibilités offertes par ce
que l'on appelle l'intercommunalité
gérard peut s'associer avec d'autres
villages alentours gérard andré
christine et benoît tous les quatre
maires de villages de 68 à 1500
habitants forment une communauté de
communes qui s'étend sur 15 km de long
et 14 km de large
le tout fait 1823 habitants à eux quatre
ils ont réussi à financer une piscine
dans le village d'andré un stade de foot
dans le bourg de christine une salle des
fêtes dans celui de benoît gérard qui
est à la tête de la plus petite commune
a pu bénéficier de l'aide des
cantonniers et du matériel des trois
autres villes pour entretenir son réseau
routier
il faut dire que pour aller du stade de
foot à la piscine tout le monde passe
par le village de gérard il y a plus de
36000 communes en france
et dix mille d'entre elles au moins de
200 habitants est donc très peu de
revenus depuis les années 60 plusieurs
lois ont organisé l'association des
communes pour mettre en commun la
gestion des déchets la distribution et
le traitement de l'eau les équipements
sportifs ou culturels
l'union fait la force c'est le principe
de l'intercommunalité
ce principe s'applique à la campagne
pour lutter contre la désertification
mais également à la ville dans les zones
urbaines
il y a souvent une grande ville au
centre entouré de vils de bonlieu avoir
un aéroport ou un grand stade pour
chaque ville n'a pas de sens
les besoins sont complémentaires souvent
la plupart des habitants de la métropole
vivent dans les villes autour et
travaille dans la grande ville au centre
il est normal que la grande ville paie
aussi pour les transports publics qui
desservent toute l'agglomération
les mises en commun sont maintenant
tellement fréquentes que les communautés
de communes deviennent des entités en
elle même dotée de fonctionnaires les
élus municipaux se choisissent parmi eux
un président de la communauté de
communes on appelle ça l'intégration
intercommunale et voilà qu'apparaît une
nouvelle couche dans le mille feuille
administratif mais comme ni la commune
ni l'intercommunalité ni le département
ni la région ne veut disparaître notre
exception française a encore de beaux
jours devant elle